so welcome to next y100 party we are
inside the building and the vest hasn't
started yet
they let us begin to film some stuff so
we're gonna
so we're here at the red carpet I'm
gonna try to squeeze my way in here and
answer some really hard-hitting
questions that you guys tweet it to me
earlier today okay here we go
I'm gonna squeeze in here I'm not very
good at this here we go you get the shot
are you getting the shot are you get the
shot or you get the shot I don't know
the shot check in with what questions
you guys got for me how do you feel
about the swine flu I couldn't be asking
the whole hood I got a bunch of
questions from the internet from a bunch
of people and I'm just gonna randomly
pick one and your opinion does this
party need more or less fudge more or
less fudge I think always more fudge say
hi to the Internet hello Internet
describe your perfect sandwich but
without words mime it
how fast can you type very fast like 120
probably that is good news the Internet
is happy about that last time I check
the thing was like oh my god
in high school I don't know it's like
120 words a minute well that's pretty
quick I'm pretty quick I probably passed
with my thumbs to my blackberry
he is Twitter at all I'm not I'm trying
to get better at it and still try to
understand it but her feed what is this
she was on Twitter are you a Twitter I'm
at Deanna Russo oh that's so exciting
obsessed with it that is totally
stalking James Franco according to page
maybe he didn't tweet if a moose the
size of a chihuahua existed what you
have one is a pet you wouldn't have the
antlers what size the antlers would be I
guess it depends I mean it depends I'm a
battler
you should probably trim them right
maybe yes of course I'm like the biggest
animal lover and I love any and a weird
animal it's like kind of strange but yes
I would have absolutely given a small
moose yes do you rather read a Maxim
magazine with your Facebook or drink Dr
Pepper with your face on the can
let's say a shark Facebook friends you
do you trust him do I trust them I do
why not I was a shark I have uh I don't
have a facebook but somebody pretended
to me to be me there for a long time at
the right the answer question want a
message what is this the answer I'm the
right stuff when pretending to me what
to do oh my god so where why do you feel
more glamorous on a red carpet as
opposed to other shades of carpet on
other shades of carpet because I don't
think anyone has red carpet in their
home unless they're Liberace so are you
working on having fun lately to have a
show out called um Harper's Island zone
that's actually a really good show yeah
it is how many people have to die before
anybody really starts to notice people
are starting to notice Natalie though I
mean it's been like it's up to like five
or six episodes now yeah
they know now I think there'll be a next
season I'm not sure is everybody dead
who cares about Kim Kardashian there's
an awesome hat in the way the real
question is where can I get a really big
sparkly LA hat with glitter sparkles
seriously now they're actually really
crazy question describe your perfect
sandwich Oh sandwich my favorite
sandwich I don't know I guess chicken
are you working on anything fun lately
you know the next album market on that
play that together can you sing me a
quick line yeah it goes I wanna touch of
butter trying to keep controlling my
hands I want to touch you but you're
probably making a left too young man
whoa I wanted to do was talk to the
office he's over there they look at him
I can't remember his name so I couldn't
call out to him
well that's it for the Maxim Hot 100
here on the red carpet which actually
we're kind of on some concrete but uh
you know what can we do um we're gonna
go in and party now so